DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Hi.
And welcome to Cloud OnAir, our
live webinars from the Google
Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Deepti Srivastava.
And I'll be talking
about Cloud Spanner.
You can ask me questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers
on the standby
that will take the questions
and give them to me
for me to answer.
Today's webinar
is kind of special
because it's called
"Stump the pros--
Does Google Cloud Spanner go
faster than the speed of light?
And other FAQs."
So your mission today, if
you choose to accept it,
is to ask me anything and
see if I can answer them
about Google Cloud Spanner.
So let's get started.
So to begin with, I just want to
give a quick overview of Cloud
Spanner just to give you
all a little bit of time
to see what clever questions
you can come up with.
And we'll go into Q&A
straight after that.
So what is Cloud Spanner?
So Cloud Spanner is GCP,
Google Cloud Platform's,
enterprise-grade,
globally-distributed,
and strongly-consistent
distributed database system.
And it's built
specifically for the cloud
to combine the benefits of
both relational database
structure and non-relational
horizontal scale.
Now what did that mean?
So essentially, we've combined
the relational semantics
of schemas, ACID
transactions, and SQL
as well as the horizontal
scale and availability
of NoSQL systems into
one fully managed
and easy-to-use relational
database service.
What that means is
you don't have to do
any more trade-offs or tuning.
So basically, you don't have
to make the decision of,
do I abandon relational
semantics to get scale,
or do I abandon scale to get the
relational semantics because I
can't actually do without
SQL and transactions
across rows and tables?
With Spanner, you
get the best of both.
So you can basically
have higher availability.
We actually offer 99.999%,
five nines of availability SLA,
for our multi-region
configuration.
And all of this is packaged up
into one easy-to-use system.
So in terms of
management, because we
are a fully managed
system, what that means is
you don't have to have the
burden and the overhead
of constantly worrying about
keeping your database up
and running.
In fact, it takes
four clicks for you
to even spin up a
globally-distributed database.
You can go to our Cloud Console.
You can just create an
instance, create a database,
create a schema.
And you're good to go.
So what that means is you
don't have to worry about,
oh my gosh, if I have
to create an index,
do I have to bring
down the database?
If I have to add
a table, do I have
to bring down the database?
There isn't any management
or maintenance windows
that you have to worry
about because all of that
is taken care of by us and
our fantastic [INAUDIBLE]
team in the background.
And you just worry
about your database
and getting the most out of it.
Because we combine
relational semantics
with scale, what that
means is that you
get to launch apps faster.
Because you don't
have to ever worry
about learning a new language.
We have ANSI, 2011
compliant SQL.
We have schemas, just like
any other relational database
that you're used to.
We have security and
high availability
built into the system so
you don't have to-- they're
not nickel-and-dime add-ons
that you have to pay for extra.
They just come part
of the package.
And all of that kind
of gets offered to you
so that you and your developers
can create the best database
that you want on
top of our solution.
All of this, by the
way, is given to you
with strong consistency.
Cloud Spanner is always
strongly consistent.
There isn't any,
which consistency
do I need to choose to get
the best out of my system?
You always get strongly
consistent data,
which means you don't
have to worry about it.
You don't have to do cross
shard transactions, any of that.
Because it's scalable,
you get all of that
built into the system.
And you never have
to worry about
inconsistent, incorrect,
inaccurate data, which
means you can just build
your application on top
of your strongly consistent
Cloud Spanner database.
And you can just go.
You never have to think about
replatforming or really crazy
bugs because of
consistency semantics
that are not met
or are not the way
you expected them to
be off your data--
which means you're always,
always getting consistent data
and always able to
create the best database,
get the best database semantics,
and build the best applications
as fast as you want.
And you can just launch and go.
So as I said earlier,
today's challenge
is to ask me anything
about Cloud Spanner.
And let's have a discussion
about distributed systems
and how we made Cloud Spanner
possible and available
to all of you out there.
Stay tuned for the live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
Welcome back.
And let's get
started with our Q&A.
So the first
question we have is,
is Cloud Spanner a
drop-in replacement
for other relational databases?
So it is a relational database.
Cloud Spanner is.
But it's also
horizontally scalable.
What that means is you
can use your schemas.
Especially for simple
relational schemas,
it should be a
complete transformation
back into Cloud Spanner.
We have DDL statements.
We have joins.
We have all that stuff.
So it shouldn't be a
problem to translate.
However-- and this is
true if you've ever
used a relational
database-- each database has
its own quirks.
And each database requires
some massaging, especially
for the more complicated
datasets and the more
complicated data types.
So in general, I don't
anticipate any problem
with taking your
relational database
and moving it to Spanner.
But there's always caveats
depending on the dataset
and the data type.
The one interesting
thing about Cloud Spanner
is that because it offers what
we call interleave statements,
which is essentially a
pre-join of your tables,
it actually allows
you to structure
within a relational database
hierarchical datasets.
And you can actually
pre-join two tables
by putting interleave
clauses in.
So you can do fast scans.
So you can think
about it as instead
of having to do a join
at every query time,
for data that is queried
together very often,
you can actually
interleave and join.
Predetermined, the
dataset is joined.
And then Cloud Spanner can take
that as a hint to quickly scan
over a bunch of data.
So hopefully that answered that.
The next question we
have is, how do you
guarantee four nines and
five nines of availability?
That's a great question.
So just to recap, Cloud
Spanner offers four nines
of availability for
our regional instances
and five nines for our
multi-region instances.
So if you look at
GCP, GCP zoned itself
by themselves offer three
nines of availability per zone.
And as you may
know, Cloud Spanner
is replicated within three
zones for the regional instance
and across three regions
and at least five zones
for the multi-region
configurations.
And multi-region
configurations differ,
so it could be all the
way up to nine zones.
So the idea is if you really
look at the probabilities,
even for the regional
instance, if you multiply out
the probabilities for 99.99%
across three zones, that's
a lot of nines.
But we know that all
failures aren't independent.
Because, for example,
within a region,
there is some
geographic correlations,
like if a meteor strikes
or something like that.
So keeping that realistic,
we offer the four nines
for the regional.
And in the multi-region case,
because we have actually
distributed the database across
multiple regions-- as I said,
at least three--
that means we are taking
care of not having
geographic correlated faults.
So in that case, we can
remove one element of risk.
And we can offer you
up to five nines.
I hope that made sense.
Our next question is, I read
about interleaved tables.
What's the advantage of that?
So I think I mentioned that in
the first question actually.
But basically, what the
interleave statement in our DDL
language is is a hint
to Spanner to say
that you will query these two
datasets very often together.
So if you have a-- let's
say you have a table albums
and another table singers.
And because you're running,
let's say, a music service,
for each user, you have multiple
albums and multiple singers.
So you constantly query for
a singer all their albums--
which means, in a
traditional sense,
you will have to do a
join of singers and albums
and then produce the results.
In Spanner's case, if you say
interleave albums and singers,
what that means is that
the system, Spanner itself,
will pre-join the
dataset and store it--
such that when you actually
query them together,
it'll just do a fast scan,
which means you avoid
the penalty of [AUDIO OUT]
So our next question is, if
I start with a single region,
is it possible to scale
to multi-region easily?
So currently, the way we
expect customers to do it
is to take an export of
their Cloud Spanner database
and then import it into a
multi-region configuration.
We hope that in
the future, we'll
have an easy solution for you
to have this as a managed thing
so you can just
tell Spanner, hey,
I want to move this database
from this single region
into a multi-region
configuration.
And you can specify both.
And you should be
able to do that.
But that's not
currently what we offer.
So our next question
is, is there
a documented migration path
from Cloud SQL to Cloud Spanner?
So there isn't a
documented path.
But we do have customer use
cases of how they've done it.
So Quizlet, for example, is an
online test study application.
And they've actually migrated
from their multiple--
I can't say how
many, but multiple--
Cloud SQL shards into one
Cloud Spanner database.
And they've written a case study
on it that you can find online.
It's linked from
our docs actually.
So you can look at that.
We have other such use
cases and stories as well.
Again, we hope to have
solutions papers for customers
to be able to do this.
And they're coming shortly.
But as of right
now, you should be
able to find information based
on the customer case studies.
Next, when would you choose
Cloud Spanner over Cloud SQL?
That's an interesting question.
So there are obviously
two use cases.
One is if you've already
been using Cloud SQL,
and you've had to go to the
sharded solution for Cloud SQL
because your dataset grew.
Or your application
got really successful,
and you have more
QPS, more queries,
coming in that your one
box Cloud SQL or even
any MySQL system can offer.
In that case, Cloud Spanner
is an obvious choice
because you don't have to
give up your wonderful SQL
and relational semantics
to be able to deal
with the scale, which
is what you would've
had to do if you chose a
scalable solution, which
was NoSQL.
And so you can just take
your Cloud SQL shards,
and then migrate over
to Cloud Spanner,
and then never have to worry
about replatforming again.
In terms of if you're starting
out with a new Greenfield
application, again,
if you expect
to be growing very quickly
either in terms of dataset
or app QPS or a combination, if
you start with Cloud Spanner,
you never have to replatform.
So you have the ability to
build this system once, and then
keep it growing, and never
have to worry about maintenance
and the hazards of,
my box fell over
because it ran out of memory,
and all those kinds of things.
However, if you're
comfortable with Cloud SQL,
and you don't think you need
any of the high availability,
or management, or scalability,
or relational semantics
of Cloud Spanner--
then if you're happy
with Cloud SQL--
you've already been building
the applications on it.
You don't expect the dataset
to grow or the QPS to grow.
And as I said, you don't
expect to be-- you've already
got all the maintenance pieces
in place and management pieces
in place.
Then by all means, if
you're happy with Cloud SQL,
please continue to use it.
Next, can I explain how
Cloud Spanner replicas
work in the background?
Does Spanner use
synchronous replication?
Yes, it does use
synchronous replication.
And I have a few slides
here that can basically
walk us through this.
But basically, as I
mentioned, Cloud Spanner
is synchronously replicated,
under the covers.
So you will only ever have to
deal with one database and one
database endpoint.
You never have to worry
about which replica
you need to talk to or rebalance
all replica-- none of that.
That's just completely
hidden from you.
You have to just worry about
talking to your database.
So we have a few
slides here, as I said.
Let's talk about the
regional configuration
first because it's the
simplest to talk about.
So as you can see here, we've
taken one regional Cloud
Spanner instance, which
has three replicas,
as I mentioned earlier.
These three replicas are
in three different GCP
zones within a given region.
We've chosen a European
region, in this case.
But it could be any GCP region.
And as you can see, there are
three read/write replicas all
off the database
within this region.
In the multi-region case,
things get a little bit more
complicated.
But the original idea
remains the same,
which is that you
have multiple replicas
across multiple
different GCP regions
across multiple different GCP
zones within those regions.
So we have three
regions in the US
in this particular
configuration.
This is one of the
configurations we actually
offer.
It's our [? nam ur Asia 1 ?]
region, which is basically
a global configuration.
So what that means is
we have the write quorum
in the US split across,
or spread across,
three different US GCP regions,
and an Asia region with two
Asia regions each having
read-only replicas,
and then a European set
which has two replicas
both in different GCP regions.
So what that means
is we've basically
distributed the data across
different geographic locations
to reduce the probability
of correlated faults
due to natural or
geographic issues.
So as you can see
here, there are
nine replicas spread across
seven different GCP regions.
Now, what does that
mean in terms of how you
interact with Cloud Spanner?
So you have one Cloud
Spanner instance
which has all these
replicas of the databases.
In that instance, you can
have more than one database
if you want in an instance,
depending on your use case.
And each of these databases
have multiple tables.
And they go to multiple
splits of the database.
So what that means is because--
so Cloud Spanner is a sharded,
synchronously-replicated
database.
And each database
actually has a full copy
of the data across the
multiple replicas, which
means all the tables
and all the data
is stored in all the
different regions fully.
And the data is
split across multiple
what we call splits
to allow it to spread
over multiple different
nodes, Cloud Spanner
nodes, to again reduce the
chances of a single failure
bringing down the whole system.
So we're parallelizing
and splitting
and sharding, all of which
is happening automatically.
So as we talked about,
there are multiple zones.
And if an update
comes in, basically we
use Paxos to replicate
the data and get consensus
into committing a write.
So in this case,
there's an update
that comes in for table
one and table two.
Let's say you want to do an
insert across both tables.
And then the Paxos
protocol we have,
which is by the way the
protocol that we wrote ourselves
to optimize-- it's not the
open-source Paxos protocol.
We have our own
optimized version of it
to again give us the performance
and high availability
that we've talked about so much.
So basically, an
update comes in.
We use Paxos to commit the
write across all replicas.
And by the time you get
the acknowledgment back
of the write-- so if
the commit succeeds,
you are guaranteed that the
data has been persisted.
And you can query it as soon
as you get the commit back.
So let's move on to
other questions here.
Hopefully, that helped.
And I can go into it in more
detail if folks are interested.
So going back to our question
set, is there a doc-- sorry,
I lost my train of thought.
How does Cloud Spanner
ensure that there isn't
a single point of failure?
So I think I covered some
of this in our discussion
so far, which is that Cloud
Spanner's both replicated
across multiple zones
and multiple GCP regions.
It's also sharded within a zone.
So a zone is where a replica, a
full copy of the Cloud Spanner
database, exists.
And now it's not one
monolithic structure.
It's sharded.
And each shard is put on
one of the multiple nodes
that you assigned
for Cloud Spanner.
So because of the sharding and
because of the replication,
we can guarantee
that there isn't
a single point of failure.
Because even if
one node goes down,
which I'll get into in a
minute of what happens in case
of failure-- but even if
one node goes down and there
are multiple nodes,
the other nodes
are up and running
to serve data.
Now I'm talking about one
of the multiple zones.
So in one zone, if you have
10 nodes and one goes down,
then at most that one tenth--
at most, one tenth of data
is supposed to be unavailable.
But because we are also
replicated across zones,
if the client notices that
one node that it was talking
to goes down, it will actually
just contact the other regions
with the same data.
So from the client or
the customer viewpoint,
you actually don't
even notice this--
on top of which,
we're constantly
monitoring the
health of our nodes
and of the system overall,
all different aspects of it.
And so we're constantly
rebalancing and resharding
these nodes and
the data on them.
So in fact, the failure scenario
isn't really a huge deal
because we are constantly
already automatically changing
the dataset, and
where it resides,
and which nodes it sits on.
So it's not a one-time event
where something happened,
and now you have a
huge outage or a blip
because the one or
two nodes fell down.
The whole thing is just
automatically managed for you.
So you, as a Cloud Spanner user,
don't even notice in most cases
that one or two nodes went down.
This is actually
one of the reasons
why we say that the SLA
is offered for at least
three nodes in an instance.
Because, as you can see,
if you have only one
node and that node went
down, then, yes, your data
is at risk, even though
there are two other replicas
that you can talk to.
But in the case of three nodes
that you get for a production
instance, there are
actually three times three
in the regional
case, so nine nodes,
that can serve your data
at any given point in time.
So that and a bunch of other
optimizations that we've made,
including the GCP network
and the full GCP stack,
allow us to have the no
single point of failure.
Because there are a bunch
of virtualized components,
all of which are constantly
rebalancing and healing.
Moving on to our next
question from the audience,
when would I consider
Spanner over BigTable?
Great question.
So Spanner is a
relational database.
I think that's the
first thing you
need to think about
when you're choosing
which data storage system you
need to use for your dataset.
Do you want a relational
database with SQL,
with schemas, with
high availability,
with cross globally available
distributed database?
Or do you not need that?
BigTable is great for
the scalability aspect
and for doing a bunch
of high-throughput reads
and writes--
such as if you have
[INAUDIBLE] et cetera,
there's a lot of information
on BigTable use cases.
But the point is it's
not a SQL database.
It's a NoSQL database.
It's horizontally scalable.
And it has a lot of
great properties.
But it doesn't offer you DDL, or
cross-role, cross-region, ACID
transactions.
It doesn't offer you SQL.
And it doesn't offer you
schemas with DDL statements.
The next audience question, how
many nodes can Spanner grow to?
How many nodes can you buy?
So Spanner is--
I don't want to use the
word infinitely scalable.
But it's designed to
be scalable seriously
to petabytes of
data and hundreds
upon hundreds of nodes.
So really, the real
question is, what
is the capacity of the cluster
or the datacenter that you
are buying Spanner in,
really at some level?
And how much money do you want
to spend to buy Spanner nodes?
But the technology
inherently is meant
to be scalable while providing
ACID transactions, which
is what makes it so cool and
why I'm so excited about it.
And I can tell you from
our internal use cases
that scaling to
petabytes of data
and the associated
compute power required
is really not a problem.
Next question, I was
wondering how long
this would take to come up.
Does Cloud Spanner
break the CAP theorem?
Absolutely not.
So the CAP theorem is about
maintaining availability
in the face of partition
and maintaining consistency
in the face of partitions.
And the way Cloud Spanner is
able to achieve availability
while having
partitions and achieve
strong consistency in
the face of partitions
is because twofold.
One, the entire
stack is designed
to have not a single point of
failure, as we talked about.
So it's got sharding,
replication, synchronous
replication, and
sharding built in.
And we, again, use the
Paxos protocol, which
means that we don't have to--
as long as we have a majority,
we can continue to write.
And as long as we have at
least one replica available,
we can actually continue
to read for a long time.
There's a really great paper
written by Eric Brewer--
who's the author
of the CAP theorem,
who's talked about CAP theorem
and Spanner and what that
means--
that I encourage anybody who's
interested to go read it.
It describes all of these
things in much more detail.
It's on our website,
cloud.google.com/spanner.
And to round out that thought,
the other reason we can do this
is because of
Google's networking.
So we have put a lot of thought
and careful instrumentation
of our networks to
make sure that we
can continue to operate across
multiple types of network
failures.
And we have a bunch of
redundancy and, as I said,
health checking and
health monitoring
built in to reroute traffic if
we notice a slowdown somewhere.
Or if we notice some
paths are blocked,
then we can kind of reroute.
All of this happening
automatically,
and the system taking
care of making sure
that we can have
availability of networks.
So the Google networking as
well as the Spanner stack both
allow us to push the limits of
CAP theorem, as I talked about.
But yes, as I said,
there's a lot more detail
in the CAP theorem
and Spanner paper
that I encourage
you guys to read.
Next question, how
well does it perform
over large physical geographies?
Well is a very interesting term.
So you can do ACID-consistent
transactions across rows,
across regions,
across datacenters,
across continents with Spanner.
And you can do them
with low latency
so that you can run
mission-critical applications
on Spanner.
And some of it has to do with
the fact that, as I mentioned,
the Google networking
is fabulous.
And we can-- the
Cloud Spanner calls--
basically, the
Cloud Spanner client
puts any incoming request
onto the Google network
as quickly as
possible so that it
can be routed to the
correct Cloud Spanner zone
to be served.
And there is
intelligence built in so
that we can choose
the closest replica
or get the fastest response.
So in terms of--
performance I think is where
you're getting to here.
And so let me talk
about some of that.
So basically, in the
multi-region instance
that we talked about earlier
that I showed a slide on,
where we have US quorum and read
replicas in Europe and Asia,
the way to think about it is
that for a multi-region Cloud
Spanner instance,
you're trading off
write latency for read latency.
So you want to have
fast reads everywhere.
And you can tolerate a little
bit of slowness for writes
in a particular region.
So what that means--
but by slowness, I'm not talking
about seconds and minutes
and none of that.
What I'm talking about is--
for example, if you have a write
coming in from Asia in this
multi-region configuration,
then we expect because of speed
of light, which we
haven't solved yet--
or we don't go faster than
the speed of light yet.
A call from Asia will
take 300 milliseconds
round-trip time, 350 maybe.
So there is that
round-trip time that you
have to take into
account for latency
over write that comes in
from Asia for US quorum.
However, if you want
to do a read from Asia,
the Cloud Spanner
client is smart enough
to go to that replica
that's closest
to it in Asia for the
type of read that you use
and give you a response.
And within a region, we expect
five millisecond response,
depending on the type
of reads that you have.
Again, these are all
very hand-wavey numbers
because it really depends on
the type of read you're doing
and the amount of data
you're reading or writing.
Like if you're writing
10 gigs of data,
then it's going to take time.
But the processing times
for Spanner itself we
have tried to optimize
as much as possible.
And we use, as I said,
again the Google network
which is highly optimized.
So RTTs, round-trip
times, are much lower
than what you would get on
the general internet in terms
of traffic.
Hopefully that
answered that question.
Next question, how is
Cloud Spanner managed apart
from the Google Console?
Does it have a Cloud
Shell or gcloud SDK?
Yes, absolutely, absolutely.
We offer the UI,
obviously, Cloud Console.
We have a gcloud SDK
that has Cloud Spanner.
And all the commands
are there for it.
And so we have a CLI.
And of course, we have the API
that you can code to directly
if you so choose.
In fact, some of
our customers wanted
to write libraries apart from
the f languages that we had.
Or they wanted to
instrument it their own way
or wanted to use REST.
So we offer GRPC-based client
libraries that you can use.
And that'd take care of a bunch
of maintenance tasks and things
like that, like transaction
retries, for example.
And we offer a REST API as
well so that you can use it.
If you have applications
that must use REST,
then you can code directly or
write your own client library
for the REST command as well.
And all of this is, by the way,
available on our documentation
on our site.
So you can, again, go to
cloud.google.com/spanner/docs.
And you should have a whole
plethora of documentation
there.
Next question, is it
recommended to use cache engines
like Memcached or Redis
with Cloud Spanner?
Or is it not necessary?
Great question.
This is one of those
things that depends.
There are a lot of
distributed systems answers
that are it depends.
So it depends on the kind
of application you have
and the latencies
that it requires.
So in most cases, Cloud
Spanner's latencies
are good enough where
you can directly
query the database itself.
And of course, we cache hot
datasets in memory, obviously.
So a lot of that is taken care
of by Cloud Spanner itself.
But if you have large datasets
or datasets that are always
being read, and you really--
like a gaming thing, if
you have a gaming app,
and there's a
bunch of users that
are playing a game
together, and they all
need to query some game
state that is not really
changing that often--
you need to flush it once in
a while back to the back end,
but mostly it needs to be served
very fast, like submillisecond
or whatever-- then you can put
a cache in front of your Cloud
Spanner database.
It might be Memcached
or Redis-- your choice.
And then serve it from there.
And then most of the QPS is
kind of handled by the cache.
And once in a while, if there is
some state change in the game,
then you can flush
it back to Spanner
and then reload the cache.
And all of that can of course--
because the database itself
is mission-critical,
is low latency,
you can expect that the cache
refreshes don't take that long.
And you can cycle them based
on your QPS cycles and things
like that.
I hope that answered that.
Next question, what
control do I have over
how the database works?
So again, this is--
I can take this so many ways.
You've set up your
database with your schema.
So there is that.
You control how
the schema works.
In terms of
introspection tooling,
if that's what you're asking, we
have a few introspection tools
already.
And there are a
bunch more that are
in the works that will be
coming out later this year.
But the first introspection
tooling that we have
is our query plan
visualization that we
have in the Cloud Console.
So what you can do is
you can run a SQL query.
You can see how the query is
performing-- whether there
are table scans that
you didn't expect,
et cetera, whether it's doing
a back join with another table
that you didn't expect.
So you can look
at the query plans
and figure out whether
your query's performing
the way you expected it to.
And you can make
adjustments based on that.
As I said, there is a bunch of
other tooling that's coming up.
We have debug tokens that
we will release soon.
We have a bunch of
things to give you
introspection into
the database of how
the queries are performing.
In terms of the
database itself, we
offer QPS metrics to see what
the throughput of your database
looks like.
We offer how many megabytes
per second it's getting
and how many QPS it's
getting and responding with.
We also obviously show
you the CPU utilization
of your database because
that's one of the key metrics
that you need in order
to figure out whether you
want to add more nodes or not.
And we offer storage metrics.
So all of these metrics are also
available through Stackdriver.
And we have a landing
page for Stackdriver
where you can see all of
these metrics combined.
And if you want to set alerts
on any of these metrics,
you can do so and see them
on the Cloud Spanner console.
So we're trying to offer
you as much of an integrated
solution as possible.
Now again, there
are those who've
been used to tinkering with
every aspect of the database.
And for them, there
is some control issue
that you will have to give up.
Because it is a managed service.
The whole point is you
don't have to worry
about how the database works.
You just have to worry about
whether your database is
looking like, or performing,
the way you expect
it to, whether your schema's
performing the way it's
expected to, whether you need
to optimize your schema or not.
And the rest of it, you
kind of have to just let
others deal with it.
You never have to--
another way to think
about it is you
never have to wake up
at 3:00 in the morning from a
pager because a node fell over,
or you're running out
of storage capacity.
We auto-scale
storage, for example.
So you never have
to worry about that.
And the only thing you
really need to think about
is, what is your
compute utilization?
And do you need to
increase compute depending
on whether your new app
has become really popular,
so you add nodes-- which by
the way, you go to the console.
You change a number in a field.
And voila, within a matter
of seconds, a few, maybe two
or three seconds,
you get new nodes.
And the same thing, you can
actually reduce nodes as well
just by changing a number.
So the idea is you don't
have to worry about managing
or maintaining the database.
The idea is you leave
the worrying to us.
Leave the pagers to us.
And you just have a happy,
running app on your database.
Next, what happens in the
event of a network failure?
So I think we talked
about this a lot.
It depends on where
the network failure is.
If you're talking about network
failure between Cloud Spanner
zones or regions, then, as I
said, in the regional case,
you have three zones--
which means if there's a network
failure from one of the zones
to the others,
then first of all,
it's Google's problem to
repair the network, not yours.
Second of all, the
other two replicas
are up and running,
as I talked about.
So they can serve your
data quite happily,
without worrying about
the third zone being down.
And by the way, because there
are a bunch of automatic things
in place, and because we have
a 24-hour [INAUDIBLE] team
that's managing and maintaining
these Cloud Spanner instances
and databases within
them, somebody will be--
I can guarantee you somebody
will be looking at this problem
and trying to get
the system back
online as quick-- for
that zone back online.
Because the rest of the
zones are available.
And to you, the Cloud Spanner
instance and databases
within it are available.
But somebody's
going to look at it
and try to bring it back online.
GCP and Google's
philosophy, actually,
is to do root cause analysis
later, to get the system up
and running, to fix the problem
first, and then go and do
root cause analysis later.
So that's the one thing.
In the multi-region
case, multiply it out.
There's so many more
replicas that you
can serve the data from that
a single network failure--
a single entire zone
failure actually
has almost no effect
on you and your ability
to serve data from
Cloud Spanner.
Hopefully that answered that.
Next question, can I dictate
where my data is stored?
So you can absolutely choose
the Cloud Spanner configuration.
And we put your database in
the instance in which you've
chosen it to be, which means
within the configuration
within which you've chosen
to put your instance.
So in the regional
case, if you choose
US central one, or EU west one,
or Asia east one for your Cloud
Spanner instance, then
your entire database,
which means all your compute
and all your storage,
is stored within that region.
In the multi-region
case, depending again
on the multi-region
configuration you choose--
and by the way,
we tell you which
regions are going to be
used in that multi-region
configuration.
So you are aware
of which regions,
which datacenters
essentially, the data is in,
which means which country or
geography or city it's in.
So you have that
level of control.
But no, you cannot pick-- if
you want to pick exactly which
zone, exactly which cluster,
your data is in, then no.
That defeats the point of having
a managed database service.
Because you then have
to worry about what
happens if the zone
goes down, or what
happens if the storage is
not available in that zone.
So you don't have
to worry about that.
If a zone goes down,
we move your data,
let's say, to a different zone.
What happens if-- if any
of those scenarios happen,
we take care of that
situation for you.
And you just talk to
one database endpoint
and continue to function.
Next question, how
do I migrate from
other relational databases?
Great question.
So right now, as I said, if
you have a simple schema,
it should be fairly simple
to take that schema,
and translate it into a
Cloud Spanner DDL language
and into a Cloud Spanner schema,
and then write data into it.
I know it's a huge
and manual process.
And I totally understand that.
We are working on various
ways for our customers
to make this easier for them.
The first thing we're working
on is an import export
functionality that should be
around in the next quarter
or so that allows you to
take files in a GCS bucket
and import them into Spanner.
Like Avro files, for
example, that you
can take a dump of your
database, put them in Avro,
put them in a GCS
bucket, and then
import them into Cloud Spanner.
You can specify the schema.
And then at least the
data migration piece
is taken care of for you.
Over time, we also are working
on simple, push-button tooling
so that especially for, as
I said, simple schemas that
don't require too much
conflict resolution,
you can just do a
simple migration
path into Cloud Spanner.
So we are definitely
thinking about that
and wanting to make
this an easy solution
for all of our customers.
So please hang in there.
And our last question--
wow, we've run out of--
last question, what makes
Cloud Spanner mission critical?
So great question.
The point of a
mission-critical database
is that it's highly available.
It's performant and allows you
to focus on delivering value
to your customers without
having to worry about database
management, maintenance,
availability, replication,
and brittle application
code that will constantly
break because the strong
consistency and all those kinds
of semantics are not being met.
They aren't ACID
transactions, et cetera.
So Cloud Spanner gives
you-- and we've talked
about a bunch of these things.
Cloud Spanner gives you high
performance, high availability,
built-in replication,
built-in security so that you
can run your absolutely
business-critical applications
on Spanner.
Business critical is
banks, and health care,
and gaming, and all of
these various scenarios
in which your business
depends on your data.
We take that very seriously.
We've been running Google's
business-critical data
on Spanner for multiple,
multiple years.
And we're basically
with that experience
saying that you can,
with peace of mind,
put your business-critical
data on Spanner.
And then you don't have to
worry about the database,
its availability,
and the ability
to use it across multiple
regions, geographies,
and continents.
So with that, I think
we're out of time.
If there are anymore
questions, I'm
happy to answer them
on the platform.
But I hope you
enjoyed this session.
And I hope some of the
questions were answered.
I have to say I
wasn't stumped so far.
But they were really
good questions.
So maybe we'll do this again.
But stay tuned in the
meantime for the next session,
coming to you live from Google
New York office in a bit.
Thank you.